we're gonna be ranking five nfl  quarterbacks before knowing the next one  so let's start this off nice the falcons  oh market for mariota five maybe i  should have went four there but marcus  mariota is not that good but he's not  the worst okay yes ma stafford give me  put him at two mariota five stafford at  two okay it's not  trey lance  yeah uh out or jimmy garoppolo because  okay i'm gonna go trey lance get trey  lance at four had to go train lands  there because the 49ers don't even want  jimmy garoppolo there  oh the chiefs practical homes that won i  need a quarterback worse than matt  stafford but better than trey lance come  on derek carr that's fair let's go